il nous faut ministres européens de
l'économie et les finances
un ministre européen qui soutiendrait
des réformes structurelles positive dans
nos états membres
il pourra se fonder sur le travail que
la commission a effectué depuis 2015
fabriquer son unité dédiée au soutien
des réformes structurelles
le ministre européens de l'économie et
des finances devraient coordonner tous
les instruments de financement dans
l'union qui doivent être mises en place
pour qu'un état membre puisse se sortir
d'une crise grave où il opérait de
récession je ne voudrais pas que l'on
créé un nouveau poste
je demande pour des raisons d'efficacité
que le commissaire chargé de l'économie
et les finances mondiales serait d'en
faire un vice président de la commission
européenne devienne smith et soit
également le vice-président de regrets